Vamos a trabajar con todo lo que hemos aprendido acerca de las potencias negativas
y para esto, este ejemplo me encanta dice:
"Categoriza el valor de cada expresión exponencial."
Y bueno nos dicen que tomemos cada uno de estos...
por ejemplo éste,
lo podremos poner en un valor que sea menor que -1,
entre -1 y 0, y entre 0 y 1.
Y bueno vamos a hacer eso, para cada uno de estos
y encontrar a cuál de estos conjuntos pertenece,
pero para eso vamos a sacar nuestras notas ¿ok?
Las tengo aquí,
ya copié aquí la parte que nos importa del problema
y vamos a trabajar con cada uno de estos,
para ver a qué llegamos.
Y dice... bueno antes,
antes de ver en dónde,
en qué conjunto está cada uno de ellos,
qué te parece si hacemos una recta numérica...
Voy a hacer una recta numérica por aquí.
¿Ok?
Ahí está, es mi recta numérica
y vamos a ver de qué intervalos estoy hablando.
Estoy hablando del intervalo que sea menor que -1,
así que si por aquí está el -1,
¿ok? vamos a poner que por aquí está el 0.
¿Ok? Y que por aquí...
por aquí está el 1 ¿Ok?
Y yo quiero categorizarlos en todos los números
que sean menores que -1...
menores que -1.
Este me va a representar justo a todos
los números que son negativos,
pero que son menores que -1,
son todos estos de aquí,
todos estos son mi primer conjunto.
Ahora también tengo los números que estén entre -1 y 0, y para eso voy a tomar este color.
Todos los números que estén entre -1 y 0...
y déjame ponerlo aquí con un asterisco,
van a ser justo estos de aquí.
Los que están aquí, van a pertenecer a este conjunto,
y por último, déjame tomar este color para hablar
de los números que están entre 0 y 1...
entre 0 y 1,
es decir, todos los que van a estar justo por aquí.
Estos son los números que van a estar entre 0 y 1,
y cada uno de estos tiene que caer
en una de estas 3 categorías  y solamente en una.
Así que vamos a empezar con el primero que dice,
4 elevado a la -4...
y lo primero que yo pienso,
cuando veo un exponente negativo,
es que este número es el recíproco de 4 elevado a la 4
ó dicho de otra manera,
este número lo podemos pensar y como lo hemos visto bastante en los vídeos pasados,
como 1, recuerda que pongo un 1
y abajo del 1 dividiendo, voy a poner 4 elevado
a la misma potencia, solamente que positiva,
4 a la 4
y quiero que te des cuenta,
qué es lo que pasa con este número.
En primer lugar, este es un número positivo,
no es un número negativo,
aunque teníamos una potencia negativa.
Recuerda que las potencias negativas no afectan el signo de mi base.
Y ahora lo que quiero también que veas
es que 4 elevado a la 4,
es un número muy grande, es como 256,
no importa cuánto sea 4 elevado a la 4,
lo que sí importa y lo que quiero que veas
es que 1 entre un número muy grande,
pues es un número muy pequeño.
1 entre 4 a la 4 es un número muy pequeño y positivo,
y por lo tanto, podemos decir que está entre 0 y 1...
por aquí va a estar 1 entre 4 a la 4,
entonces, bueno ya sabemos que éste de aquí,
esté de aquí va a ir a dar a los números
que están entre 0 y 1...
a los números que están entre 0 y 1 va a ir para acá...
Ok, vamos a trabajar con el segundo que dice
- 4 elevado al cubo...
- 4
elevado al cubo.
Y bueno en este caso lo primero que pienso es que
-4 elevado al cubo,
es exactamente lo mismo que -4 por -4,
por  -4,
y bueno, esto lo podemos representar
de la siguiente manera,
esto es lo mismo que -1
por 4,
y esto a su vez por -1,
y esto a su vez por 4,
y después otra vez por -1
por 4...
y lo estoy escribiendo de esta manera,
porque quiero que te des cuenta
que aquí tengo 1, 2, 3 veces -1 multiplicándose
es decir, que esto es lo mismo que -1 elevado al cubo,
ok,
y esto a su vez por 4 por 4, por 4,
es decir, por 4 elevado al cubo.
Ahora, -1 elevado al cubo,
es exactamente lo mismo
que -1,
esto es lo mismo que menos...
menos...
el signo se conserva,
y aquí voy a poner 4 elevado al cubo
y bueno, tú también lo podrías visualizar
exactamente igual desde aquí arriba
esto es exactamente lo mismo que,
menos por menos, más, por menos, menos
4 por 4, por 4,
es 4 al cubo.
Y lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que éste,
este número 4 elevado al cubo,
si solamente nos fijamos en esta parte de aquí, déjame cambiar el color...
solamente nos fijamos en esta parte de aquí,
4 elevado al cubo, es un número muy grande,
4 elevado a los cubo es como 64,
y ahora,
si nosotros lo multiplicamos por menos,
voy a encontrar la versión negativa de 4 elevado al cubo,
por lo tanto, si 4 elevado al cubo
es un número muy grande,
cuando lo multiplicó por menos, me va a dar
un número muy negativo o dicho de otra manera,
-4 elevado al cubo es un número que está
entre los números que son menores que -1,
es un número muy negativo
y por lo tanto ya tenemos la respuesta de éste,
-4 elevado al cubo,
es un número que va a ir justo aquí
en los números que son menores que - 1.
Ok, pues vamos a trabajar con el siguiente.
Tengo -4 elevado a la -4, lo voy a poner por aquí,
- 4 esto a su vez elevado a la -4.
Y bueno, recuerda que aquí tenemos
una potencia negativa,
entonces, lo primero que pensamos cuando tenemos una potencia negativa, es en el recíproco
o en nuestras fórmulas,
que nosotros nos hemos aprendido,
en la ley de los exponentes,
que me dice que esto es lo mismo que 1 entre - 4...
- 4...
elevado a la cuarta potencia.
Ahora lo que quiero que veas es que
-4 elevado a la cuarta potencia,
lo puedo desarrollar justo como está aquí,
-4 elevado al cubo,
solamente que por una vez más,
pero al final llegamos a -1 elevado al cubo,
por 4 elevado al cubo,
así que esto...
esto siguiendo ese mismo patrón,
es 1 entre  -1 elevado a la cuarta potencia,
por 4,
elevado a la cuarta potencia,
¿y por qué lo escribo así?
Porque -1 elevado a la cuarta potencia es
menos por menos, más,
por menos, menos, por menos más,
es un número positivo, es 1, de hecho,
entonces esto es lo mismo que,
1 entre 4 elevado a la 4,
y 1 entre 4 elevado a la 4 es un número
que ya sabemos dónde estaba,
es justo éste de aquí,
y nosotros concluimos que este número que
estaba aquí, es un número que está entre 0 y 1...
entre 0 y 1
y por lo tanto -4 elevado a la -4
también es un número que está entre 0 y 1,
porque es de hecho exactamente lo mismo
que 1 entre 4 elevado a la 4.
Entonces éste de aquí... éste de aquí,
voy a concluir que es un número que está entre...
por acá,
entre 0 y 1, de lujo.
¿Ok? Vamos con éste de aquí...
vamos a cambiar de color...
y voy a trabajar con este color...
Dice -4 elevado a la -5...
lo voy a poner aquí...
-4 elevado a la -5
y tengo una potencia negativa,
entonces, lo primero que voy a hacer es poner 1 entre -4...
-4 elevado a la quinta potencia,
es decir, a la versión positiva de -5,
y bueno, esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 1 entre...
y siguiendo el mismo patrón que tenemos aquí arriba,
que -1 elevado a la quinta por 4 elevado a la quinta...
es una forma de verlo,
o lo podemos ver también como que aquí tenemos
5 veces multiplicándose el signo menos,
y entonces esto me va a dar un número negativo,
esto es lo mismo que -1 entre 4
elevado a la quinta potencia.
Ahora, quiero que te des cuenta de algo,
si yo me fijo aquí en 1 entre 4 a la 5,
éste de aquí
por la misma razón que 1 entre 4 a la 4
es un número que está entre 0 y 1,
1 entre 4 a la 5 también es un número
que está entre 0 y 1,
de hecho, es un número más pequeño
que éste de acá arriba.
Sin embargo aquí tengo a este número que es pequeño,
es decir, que está entre 0 y 1,
pero su versión negativa,
y su versión negativa,
va a ser un número que está entre -1 y 0,
lo único que estoy haciendo es tomar un número de aquí y volverlo negativo,
y entonces lo paso para acá.
Entonces en este caso, 1 entre 4 a la 5 negativo,
es un número que está entre -1 y 0,
la versión negativa de un número muy pequeño
por lo tanto, éste de aquí...
déjame cambiar de color,
éste de aquí va a ser un número que está entre -1 y 0
Ok, y vamos a pensar en este último de aquí, tengo
-4 elevado a la quinta...
-4 elevado a la quinta.
Esto es exactamente lo mismo que
-1 elevado a la quinta, por 4 elevado a la quinta,
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que menos
-1 por -1, por -1, por -1, por -1,
es un número negativo
por 4 elevado a la quinta,
y bueno, 4 elevado a la quinta
es un número muy grande,
y si yo tengo un número muy grande
pero en su versión negativa,
pues es un número menor que -1,
es un número muy negativo,
entonces de igual manera,
voy a concluir que éste de aquí...
éste de aquí es un número
que es menor que -1, va a ir justo aquí.
Ok y ya tengo la solución de estos 5 ejercicios.
Así que vamos a acomodarlos
y espero que tenga una buena memoria
para recordar dónde va cada uno.
Regresemos aquí a la página...
a la página de Khan Academy.
Tengo esta página aquí, dice,
"Categoriza el valor de cada expresión exponencial."
4 elevado a la -4,
bueno pues esto quedamos que es
el recíproco de 4 elevado a la 4
por lo tanto, es lo mismo que 1 entre 4 elevado a la 4,
que es un número que está entre 0 y 1.
Ok,
-4 elevado al cubo...
bueno, este se nota que es un número menor que -1,
porque tengo -4 por -4, por -4,
un número muy negativo,
por lo tanto, es un número menor que -1
y este también era un número menor que -1, así que vamos a acomodarlo justo ahorita también aquí.
-4 elevado a la -4...
¡Oh! Recuerda este ejercicio...
esto es lo mismo que
1 entre -4 elevado a la 4,
ya habíamos concluido que es exactamente lo mismo,
que 4 elevado a la -4, que estaba justo acá abajo.
Entonces lo voy a poner aquí,
ok,
y por último tengo -4 elevado a la - 5,
y este era el que estaba entre -1 y 0,
porque esto es lo mismo
que 1 entre -4
elevado a la quinta potencia.
Ok, perfecto.
Y ahora si ya tengo cada una de las expresiones categorizadas y vamos a comprobar la respuesta...
Vamos a comprobar respuesta...
¡Y perfecto!
Ya tenemos la respuesta y estamos bien.
Por lo tanto, es todo por este vídeo hasta la próxima.